if I was a god smoking weed all day you
know I mean they didn't have a job I was
like I'm a comedian but just never went
up I mean that'd be one thing but no I
was gung-how you're hustling I was
hustling for sure because when you think
that I honestly believe that it was my
only way out
that's the thing it's like there is no
other option it's like if this doesn't
work out for me I'm [__] that's how I
feel I feel that way right now yeah I'm
[__] like I have to go like if you if
you don't keep going it just is what it
is and like you know respectfully I
myself like I'm in a great financial
place I've built a lot for myself it's
incredible but
I still I feel uneasy I felt uneasy
today these last few days and I think
um
yourself man you're cute no it's not
that it's really just like when you
could do anything like bro I have a New
York Times best-selling novel you know
what I mean I I have dozens of albums
I've been in film and television and
stuff like that and that's I'm still
young and I know that but there's still
this sense of uneasiness and you know
what it's actually a really beautiful
feeling because I don't feel complacent
I don't feel like I got it all and I
feel like logic has to fight for
everything every view every stream
everything and
that's okay because if I woke up every
day and just didn't give a [__]
it wouldn't be worth it to me do you
want to hear the bad news yeah please
that will never go away
damn but I kind of like it I know it's
weird it's so weird because I feel
like I'm in the basement
again you know because now what I really
want to do more than anything is you
know I'm going to start my own podcast
which I think that's [__] gonna kill
it you're so good we'll see I don't know
it's gonna be great hopefully and then
also I really want to produce other
artists and I want to change the
trajectory of my career I love rapping I
love singing I love making music but I
really love the idea of producing kind
of stepping back I mean still I'm always
rap and [__] but
I'm out of I'm on the cusp of something
personally incredible
and I don't know what's going to happen
and that makes me scared
and the fact that I'm scared makes me
happy because I it matters to me and and
who knows what a viewer or listener may
think of you know logic's got you know
went to Grammys did all the stuff
I wake up every day and fight for the
future of my children of my fans and of
spreading a good message so it's
exciting wow I I have a feeling that um
all kinds of Secrets you know honestly
like you know I'm privy to you on the
internet and this and that right but in
terms of like I've never met you before
have we met before no no no no so it's
like you really when I like I'll be
honest when I first saw you I I thought
and that's not gay well now it is
scary what are you gonna say are you
sure no no no that's no dick there's no
dicks involved okay all right I I I I
went um oh he's cute cute okay yeah I
mean but none of like you know like in a
prison maybe yeah all right that's sweet
I don't know what that has to do with
success but I appreciate it I think he
just wanted to share that one I need to
share my feelings yeah that's my first
thing and I'm like oh he's nothing like
even when you start talking nothing like
I thought it would be you know what I
mean you know I get that a lot yeah and
I actually I actually I think that's the
gift and the curse of the internet no
you're so like you're thoughtful you're
mindful about what you say you're right
guy you know you seemed like a really
nice guy I just you know I'm enamored by
it you know I mean you know it's not gay
I mean I'm down yeah yeah I don't want
to [__] you man let's make out right no
I don't know it's like weird I'm sorry I
wanted to say it again okay everyone
back up everything's fine but no but but
there's something about you that was
like you know whatever you're saying or
whatever you want to do I believe that
you can do it you know what I mean I
think it wasn't until recently and I'm
still figuring it out exactly what I
want to do but like I said from the
podcast to uh to production and just
kind of going into a new step in my
career I think that that's what it is
manifestation is a real thing dude like
I think about how many is it things
because I believe that is who is it no
no no no no listen I believed it too I
really did